[Musique]
des révoltes c'est une application où
les citoyens peuvent souscrire à des
sujets qui les intéressent comme la
santé la famille l'environnement et être
informés alerté de toutes les nouvelles
propositions et projets de lois générés
par le sénat le gouvernement et
l'assemblée nationale
ça leur permet ensuite de réagir de
voter pour ou contre et de recevoir de
questions de leurs députés directement
dans leur poche pour prendre part au
débat et à la création des lois c'est
tout simple il suffit de télécharger
l'app sur l'apple store qu'on a sur un
iphone et sur android sur le google play
et là on va simplement pouvoir
s'inscrire indiqué son code postal
indiqué cette thématique de préférence
et ça y est c'est près on va être
informé de qui sont ces députés et des
dernières à l'ancienne des derniers
textes etc c'est d'épouser sur les
sujets qui nous intéressent de très
étudiée vote parce que j'avais bien
conscience de la montée de la
contestation vers la démocrate yves et
je me suis rendu compte qu'en fait il
manqué pour le citoyen énormément de
façon de s'impliquer entre les élections
arrivent l'élection suivante je suis
frustré et la plupart du temps j'utilise
mon vote pour exprimer la frustration
plutôt que pour donner la bonne
direction au pays les informations à
disposition des citoyens sur les sites
de l'assemblée du synode n'était pas
synthétique et il y avait besoin d'un
moyen technique pour en créer une
synthèse une vulgarisation et la portée
est près de tout